good morning Millennials let's try that
again okay well I thought it was sounded
good oh I just I don't feel like I gave
it my all like I did my performance at
your wedding great segue hi everyone
welcome back to the morning show started
we were gone yesterday we were busy
recovering and honestly it did nothing
because I feel like the wedding was last
night that's how bad I feel I feel the
way I should have felt yesterday like
just in pain yesterday I felt like death
before the high the high carries you
through high carry me through the videos
carried me through like reliving every
contem carried me through and the
toaster is [ __ ] with their excitement
carry me through to today I was
literally laying in bed may or may not
be suffering from a concussion which
will get me get into it and I was like
there's no way I can get out of bed and
I was like if I don't go do the toast
right now like I will have thirty
thousand toasters banging down my door
no Jackie right so I got up and I got
out of bed for you and I'm glad I did
because like I need to recap I haven't
properly like rehash the night you know
cuz we weren't together right I've done
it in bits and pieces like with
different people but like I'm so excited
to go through every detail and then you
remember news stories and I want to hear
like the funny things that happened - I
have so many things to say well welcome
back you guys thanks for just you know
really being there all night for us
capturing content because what's so
funny is like obviously I'm not watching
my own stories or anyone else's stories
of the wedding but literally the screen
recordings in the toasters group on all
the fan accounts like really just the
memories live on forever hold on to the
memories they will hold on to you
the memories lived on forever and like I
enjoyed my night so thoroughly it was an
amazing night which will get tuned is so
beautiful and I had one I had my own
personal experience but watching the
morning toast lingo was I would say like
the premier account the royal wedding I
was just messaging with her she was the
royal wedding correspondent she was
Melanie Bromley couldn't agree more and
so watching it she compiled every single
story of every single guest who was
there and so you're really seeing it
from every different angle and
everyone's different perspectives and
like I really got a sense of like how
everyone was feeling about the wedding
and oh my god everyone had the best time
no everyone had the best time
congratulations by the way how do you
feel different now I feel great
like as you guys know the wedding
planning process was really really
stressing me out and like the day was so
beautiful and you know at the end of the
day
I married Zack and so even if the day
was a big old turd I would be happy
right now and I'm just I'm so happy that
all of that was worth it all of the like
treachery of planning and all the
details like our wedding was very like
detail-oriented and detail heavy and
everything just like all of the hard
work really paid off because it was so
so magical it was so special just as a
guest but also someone who was you know
a little bit more involved than the
average guest it was just a world wind
and you know sometimes you go to a
wedding and it's like it's great it's
fun the flowers are pretty but it's like
the couple really makes the wedding it
really it doesn't matter how much money
you spend it's like if the couple is in
love you could be on a dirt road and
it's like everyone's there for the
couple and then sometimes a couple is
like you know they're not so you know
excited and it makes it whatever yeah
the end of the day it didn't matter
where we were cuz if you exactly go
really and you guys aren't very PDA in
the beginning of your relationship you
were like annoying PDA like didn't stop
touching each other like everyone wants
to kill you what's like talking [ __ ]
about you behind your back then you guys
like got normal like everyone else and
then now you like at the wedding you
really just showcased like all good
sides of your relationship like the
happy side the funny side the dancing
side the emotional side the connection
side like you know like yeah besides it
was all the sides and so and that was
really nice for me too and I didn't
realize it was happening into like I
watched a video of our first dance and I
was like oh my God we're so sweet and
like so many questions about your first
dance and most of them come for me so
basically what we're gonna format the
show is Jack and I are just gonna recap
shoot the [ __ ]
then I gathered questions from Facebook
from Twitter from Instagram if you
follow us in Instagram bill leave a
comment on the picture all I might breed
it if it's a good question like I want
good questions I don't want like what
was the peak Mo's appeal like a good
[ __ ] o P key and there was one pit
and that maybe I should address my
question let's jump right in let's jump
right in
so the wedding was it was wild and he
was rowdy and what you were saying it's
all about the couple but it's like I
feel like every time Zak and I go to a
wedding like we are always on the dance
floor we just bring so much energy for
whoever the couple is like we just love
that so when you go to someone else's
wedding like I always go to someone
else's wedding with the same energy that
they bring up in general couldn't agree
you know what I mean cuz it's like if
they're a low-key couple it's like I
don't want to be a trashy like drunk
girl on the dance yeah like I'm gonna
keep it classy but if it's like a really
fun couple it's like oh my god they want
me to be fun just like that yeah so I
feel like everyone really brought the
same energy that we always bring and for
that reason but it was it was Pam it was
packed everyone what like not only was
everyone dancing like boogying but
everyone was [ __ ] hyped up oh my god
and Mary Ann Bennett an element music
just like only added to that like I
think everyone was so excited to dance
but then they were like they would have
danced to elevators yeah but then they
were blown away by Mary Ann Mary Ann
it's the same band that I had my wedding
I've seen her and a few other weddings
that I go to in the city like she's like
the greatest fan and when it comes to
wedding and budgeting I think the only
thing I think you can budget and cut
corners on a lot of things but the band
is not one of them the band is
responsible for not only creating an
atmosphere getting like everyone hyped
up but also like moving things along and
keeping like an order to the night and
she is a true professional and she's so
funny and if you really just watch her I
really stood it at the front of the
dance floor for like a good seven
minutes you could learn a lot from her
you just watching because so she
obviously sings but she's not the lead
singer she's the bandleader and so she
transitions from song to something like
the guy in the guitar doesn't know
what's playing next she runs around she
says I got a feeling and then chill at
the end of at the end of it Alicia Keys
song will be like tutu and [ __ ] and then
everyone in the band knows here's their
ears they hear Mary Ann and then they go
into it it's all like improv it's so
crazy how they like transition and like
mesh songs and she is such a nut letting
also mash songs up like so there were
certain songs that I did not want to
hear at my wedding but exactly kind of
liked them and want to see here then she
was like don't worry I'll mash it up so
with if they're playing you know what's
a song I don't like shout shout but that
was that was Jackie's odd number but it
exactly one hear shout she would have
smashed up shout with Kelly Clarkson and
therefore we're both happy
no they just so I think everyone was so
excited to dance and have a great time
and then the band just like brought it
to another level of spectacular like the
dance floor was just jump in everyone's
dancing wildly and at one point Zach and
his brother Kyle started crowd surfing
I'm up there like my be dressed no
Jackie go so I jump into the crowd I'm
crowd surfing I am popping like popcorn
and balloons I'm being nuts like they're
throwing me and it's like I'm not trying
to be caught in like
you
I know it was so it was honestly I like
turned around and Zack was in the air I
was like holy [ __ ]
then she come flying out of nowhere
Jackie like you were up like four or
five feet in the air right yeah wild so
I mean it made sense that I fell but um
unfortunately a man fell on my head and
today I'm suffering but everyone I spoke
to dockter's about it they said if it's
been more than six hours and I'm not
feeling nauseous or dizzy then I'm
probably not concussed and the bruise
really does feel external not internal
it's like when I touch it it's black and
blue but I'm not feeling it like on the
inside like a headaches so I think I'm
okay knock on what I will be I would
keep you guys updated but so yesterday
was really a struggle for me because not
only was I hungover I don't even know
what was hangover and what was concussed
but it was a painful painful day anyways
let's take it from the beginning of the
day are you still feeling pain right now
yes but like as I sit here in this
moment no but like when certain consults
doctor yes I consult in my uncle John
who is an ER doctor and he said that
that it sounds like I'm okay and I had
already I've slept and I'm and I can and
I'm here I knew if I say anything crazy
today just blame it on the concussion
well you know maybe I need to consult
Uncle John as well because I too have a
wedding-related bruise you want to say
what is it do you have those from your
chin you see this little red thing or
did I cover it up with makeup you cover
I see it oh there's like a big red mark
on my chin and it has like little dots
and lines in it and I couldn't remember
what it was from but then of course I
remember when the DJ at the after-party
played shallow you handed the mic over
to me and I was about to ha ha ha ha and
I was just like feeling the mic and the
mic I was like yeah and I went to like
sing and then Mike hit me in the jaw and
I like it was so painful and now there's
like a full Umbra's mic related incident
singers get them all the time it's not a
big deal apparently the video was
playing and you didn't hear the story of
oh how I got concussed so let me tell it
one more time in real in the pain I'm
popping like popcorn as you've seen in
the video multiple times four or five
feet I see Zach then I see Jackie and my
dress is so big you don't know where I
am within the dress and where's the
dress so even if you catch dress you're
not catching me so inevitably they drop
me I fall I hit my head lightly on the
floor I'm I'm okay I'm picking myself up
and someone else who was in the I think
was hoisting me out was a fighter
otherwise just a drunk person fell on my
head
asked ahead I hit the ground again and
like where this man's asked it my head
is like where I am suffering today so
it's not where your head hit the floor
it's where the ass at the head yes and
then Oh Joe who the man was right do you
know who the man was and you know he's a
wild guy but I'm sure he was also just
good you're not gonna you're not gonna
slander a man before noon I'm not gonna
send our man before noon and for a while
I didn't know who it was so and it was
kind of good in then when I found out
who it was it's like okay I can't help
but hate you almost like ruin my post
wedding day I was suffering immensely
but in case you also didn't hear I have
consulted doctors my uncle John is a
near art
ER doctor he said if it's been more than
six hours and I'm not feeling nauseous
or blurry vision or dizzy or anything
like that which I'm not then I should be
okay I've already slept twice now and
the pain really does feel external not
internal it feels just like a black and
blue mark on my head so you know it was
the crowd-surfing related injury I seem
to be okay when I got honestly when I
got up in the fall and everyone was like
are you okay like waiting for me but
yeah and I was not okay no we're so hot
from like the pillow yeah and like my
hair and my bun I would [ __ ] wanted to
cry but I was like no and I ignored the
pain for the rest of the night and in
the morning like I don't even know how I
did that you know what it sounds like
you have a case of what ticket to demand
iosys when Jack Black in the beginning
of the movie crowd surfs and nobody
catches him and he hits the floor that's
you know yes they were all there like it
was a it was a successful crowd surfing
and it would've been okay had I just
fallen from the concept cuz you know it
was a controlled fall but this man's
fault was not controlled and my head
broke his ass that's the thing about
sticking to the Manteo --ss it can break
your ass right okay so I say we just
jump right in we've been gathering
questions on Facebook on the gram just
so many questions for you okay
I really hope there are so many moments
and so many things I want to talk about
so I really hope that we get to all of
them
okay just give me one minute to find oh
wow so maybe there aren't that many
questions no there are so many questions
I literally can't okay okay let's talk
about the emotions
okay the crying as a consumer of the
party just not even that just I couldn't
stop crying I mean this saram I cry at
most ceremonies and then after that it's
like I'm on a high drinking partying but
I literally didn't stop crying the
entire night well I'm so glad
because that you know was a goal but I
didn't do anything to elicit crying at
certain times so I'm but I'm glad cuz I
love to cry at weddings and that's a
sign of like a good wedding um aside
from all the fun so for me like I get
really emotional at your wedding I was
so much in Olivia's wedding and I was
curious like how a motion I would be at
my own wedding and like that's not
really logistically that's not gonna
work out because of the makeup and you
know everything and so there were a few
times during before the before the
actual ceremony where I was like got
kind of emotional I was like praying
with my friends and that was really cute
and I was starting to cry and then when
I started to walk down the aisle I was
like starting to smile cry when I saw
Zach and like everything but it wasn't I
didn't get crazy because I think I was
also really overwhelmed and I also just
felt like really good about what I was
doing you know it was like when I look
at you guys walking down the aisle and I
just think about like oh my gosh make
some beautiful sisters I'm so happy for
them I'm so overwhelmed and for me I was
just I just felt like this is where I'm
supposed to be right now and like I'm
just happy and so if my big smile turns
into a tear it's like it won't go to the
tears aren't streaming you know God
knows left to cry right well you said
something really interesting like the
day before your wedding which I couldn't
agree more with and it's like in our
family like you're kind of like the
Kourtney Kardashian or at least like
when we were growing up no I I still AM
like I feel I I consider we're just only
in terms of the emotion not I'm not like
a super emotional person I am very like
rational and logical so like if
something hurts my feelings but I know
that it's not intended to or that and
that's not how it was men he will no
longer hurt my feelings you know what I
mean like I'm able to separate logic
from emotion yep oh so Jackie basically
said you really are I feel like out of
all of us weirdly like the most
emotional and also the most like not
emotional like you really have a good
ability to compartmentalize and that
everyone's wedding like you cried most
yeah out of everyone like at Olivia's
wedding you totally cried the most I
don't remember at mind bail you really
are I kind of most at your wedding and I
think you like I really was impressed
with how intact you were with your
emotions I think it's a good thing yeah
I think it's a good like I'm really
grateful that I didn't like lose my [ __ ]
at all also I saw people are commenting
about people being on their phones and
then laughter I said something in the
patron episode we did a pre-wedding
patreon about you know my expectations
for my wedding which are now funny when
you listen back and then we're going to
do a post-wedding patreon you know
recapping even more and answering more
questions but I said like I want my
ceremony to be dead serious like silence
no laughter no phones like you could
hear a pin drop and on a few occasions I
broke my own rules first of all the
announcement for phones not to be used
wasn't made until after I walked down
the aisle and you know what I am so glad
yeah my walk down the aisle was well one
like the walk was was so beautiful a
song that was playing and it was just
like such a beautiful like moment with
my mom but also Burch did this thing
with um silhouette silhouette like
Project Runway style where at first like
they put this screen in front of me in
the light and you only see my silhouette
of my dress and it was just like it was
cool and dramatic and I'm glad that
everyone like recorded it cuz I got to
see it over and over again when you
waved and then I was standing there it
was long it was long and also I wanted
people to realize that it's live this is
not even sure I put up so I just and I
you know me like as much as I want to be
serious like I'm still me so I just did
a little wave just something new as me
Jackie it was so funny we were dying you
wanted like you looked so petite like it
looked like there was a child by a child
bride behind the street and it was just
like it was just like the cutest little
like motionless wave it was amazing it
was so funny it was I also hate when
people left but he was the perfect
little laughter gem of an it was just so
funny
I agree and you know what like it was it
was perfect and that's who I am
know so I listened a little after maybe
I'm a big comedian that Rocky
it was everything like I was dying and
actually missed it I saw it on video but
then whenever left I'm like what
happened mugger was like she waved and I
don't even see it and I was like that's
hilarious that's so funny so then I did
my little wave and then we walk down to
the tune of never enough but the words
were Bowie collar which is here comes
the bride but it was sung in Hebrew -
Bowie Kayla Bowie Bowie so beautiful
Marion did my ceremony also lovely Orca
sucking crushed it bit songs that people
walk down to which like we're so
important to me in choosing where first
when the room opened they played maestro
from the holiday which was Marion's
choice and it was so beautiful it's like
Hans Zimmer then Zac walked down to earn
our Kestrel version of just the way you
are by Bruno Mars
exact some strings dududududu exactly's
playing the melody so is beautiful then
a grandparent's walked down to tale as
old as time instrumental and precious
they were their precious gems of humans
so it was only fitting they had a
precious song and then the Steen's and
Carly and AJ Zak sister and her fiance
walked down to orchestral version of
yellow by Coldplay
it was Oh yellow which is my [ __ ]
love that song and I have no clue like
where ranks in terms of like overused or
basic over there but I was just like in
my soul like I love this song and I
think it's beautiful and I want everyone
to what it was lovely I can't remember
if it's that song or a different
kool-aid song that's in crazy rotations
I don't know but whatever it's a
beautiful wedding song and I loved it
were you inspired heavily by crazy rich
visions that's a question we got a lot
no no no not at all but I thought it
like it I guess if they played yellow
then that would have been the biggest
inspiration and then my mom and I too
but we come on never enough greatest
showmen and it was just perfect there
were three major greatest showmen
moments in the wedding which were so
important to me to have so that was the
first then when Zach and I are announced
into the ballroom
they did huh and they did and then Zach
and I came out to this is the greatest
show it was the perfect song to come out
to Yankee like everyone was so hyped I
didn't there was like I don't know I
feel like I talked to you more than
anyone in the world I think I talked to
you more than Zach and I knew nothing of
like what was gonna happen I was just
like every turn so surprised you know
like yeah that was me the whole night
that's so but and then we had the
sparklers which were all Zach he was
like hell bent on getting sparklers and
fog and I was personally because the
whole time it was like oh yeah that'd be
a great idea but we don't need it we
don't need this we don't need that and
there's a lot of things like we didn't
need and we didn't have but he really
wanted fog and sparklers and like he was
so right so let me run the sparklers for
the first dance so when you walked out
the sparklers were just like a nice
thing in the background like they were
worried I didn't notice them until I saw
them in other people's video wasn't
really a focal point but at your first
dance was just already just so beautiful
that song is so stunning the little fog
cloud smoke which was like a little
extra surprise and then the sparklers
like who knew and like they're just in
these little boxes so you think it's
like a light like yeah notice it doesn't
say fire and I didn't know either and so
for our first dance I always knew I
wanted to dance to a million dreams and
it's like those opening piano notes like
they make me cry because like even
during like the the pits of wedding
planning like I would just think about
what it was gonna feel like to dance at
song so like immediately when the song
started playing like I was just like we
were hugging and dancing and like I was
crying and then I picked my head up and
open my eyes and we're surrounded by fog
and I had no idea that that was gonna
happen did you choreograph your dance at
all
no and really I was saying he was like
we need to choreograph it a little bit I
was like we're two great dancers like I
don't think that we need to and Marianne
was like no just one night like get a
bottle of wine and start dancing your
apartment you'll figure it out
and we always intended to do that but we
had no time I mean I don't really
thought you guys I could take let had
taken lessons and I was like these
memories are going to do lessons behind
our backs was the first time we had ever
done a no I mean the twirl was just oh
my god
it was so we were just like spinning and
you know we're capable people we love a
good dip and it was all just like so
beautiful and then as the sparklers were
going off and I was started twirling and
I was just like in the moment I was like
I thought you totally planned the twirl
no oh my god I have a sands in the air I
was just feeling it it was so Dancing
with the Stars I was basically your
audition
totally like Dan's gonna start I am
still available I was just feeling the
twirl and I twirled out I want to talk
about your dresses I mean it was
probably we got the most questions yes
you wore three I wore three it moves in
true Jacki fashion I didn't intend to
because like literally as of a week
before my wedding I was just wearing
that first one the whole night but then
things changed so the first dress that I
wore was Carolina Herrera
from the wedding sign of Manhasset I
can't stress highly enough how if you're
in New York you need to go to the
wedding sonim and I said they have
everything like it is an Emporium of
wedding kachou and like hoochie coochie
and like most wedding funds you know
they know what they're doing my
tailoring was impeccable but I just feel
like their selection and their
collections yeah so this dress actually
was the first dress I ever tried on
which is honestly the worst thing and it
looked so good and I was like well I'm
gonna look incredible in every dress
right so I tried on about 20 more and I
didn't I looked okay but I didn't look
it it wasn't it wasn't this dress so I
was like okay this is the dress for me
and I
honestly from the first time I tried it
on to the first time I went for a
fitting which was like four or five
months apart I like knew that it was a
great dress but I was like you know it's
a little bit of a risk because it is
it's like three-tiered it's poofy I look
like a cake and it's just it's an
interesting choice and I even saw so
many comments like no one like everyone
loved the dress but I was like this
really wasn't what I was expecting and I
didn't have any expectations for myself
but I wasn't expecting that I never seen
a dress like that in my life
no me neither you know stunning it was
stunning it's just like so ethereal it's
like princess but it's also not it's
traditional but it's also modern it's
just everything so I was just so excited
about the dress and for a while I wanted
to just like cut it off and make it a
mini dress but then I was like who am I
to [ __ ] with Carolina Herrera know what
and I couldn't agree more because many
said that I'm like this girl has lost
her mind right and a lot of people said
that um so I was like okay then we were
shopping for the amfAR gala this was two
weeks ago I ordered a bunch of dresses
online and I saw this second dress this
white dress and I was like oh my god
that's a beautiful dress and it was like
if I wear that dress to amfAR I would
have gotten my picture taken of course
right that was my thinking so I ordered
it just to see like what it would look
like and it didn't come time for amfAR
came a few days later so I got and I was
like ready to send it back but I said
you know let me just try it on because I
really only ordered it to try it on just
to like see the beauty of the dress and
I put it on and it fit like perfectly he
didn't need a hem didn't need a stitch
well that's great I never got it happen
it had a hoop skirt in it so it just
went out and like everything just fits
so perfectly I was like I love that it
was FaceTime with mom and she was like
that's a wedding dress I know it's done
there and it fit me perfectly like a
glove how can I send it back no you can
and at the same time I'd place this
order at ASOS that I totally forgot
about I didn't open it for days because
I forgot what was in there and I just
opened it so I was going through my
packages and it's a glass slipper and it
was literally Cinderella I literally
felt like Cinderella with a glass
slipper deliver it on my doorstep so I
was like okay now I'm wearing two
wedding dresses and then the more I
thought about I was like that is Who I
am
I'm Wed Hodel it and one of the I saw
someone commented they were like I love
how she wore a poufy dress and then
changed it to an even poufy dress yeah
usually it's like you changed it to
something a little lighter right and you
know what I
[ __ ] and I knew that I couldn't party
all night in it especially for the
after-party which turned into a club
frat house at the pier it was a Phi Beta
Pierre yeah yeah no PR Beta Kappa we
should have made such jokes
totally you could only dream that your
after-party will turn into a frat house
I really have assumed that everyone
wants to say all night and party and
drink and eat like and write you just
can't assume that but so I just wanted
to make sure that it was like there was
something there if people wanted to say
but I wasn't pressuring anyone and I
just hoped it would be fun and lit and
then the third dress I changed in she
was literally like so last-minute I
ordered so many after-party dresses and
or tried to their size I would have worn
anything and I found this like Marchesa
dress it's on sale it was like too big
on me I took it to the tailor I was like
tight and short and make it happen
and they did Jack's we have to talk
about the elephant in the room we need
to talk about the Marchesa of it all
people you know there were some comments
oh I would love to know your thoughts
there were some comments and I also
where my keys are to answer an FIR or
casein note because it's cheaper right
here are my thoughts on Marchesa because
I was slamming her with every day you
and Schwartz leader I was a big tour
leader and I was like hold Georgina
accountable yes and you know what
Georgina has been held accountable and I
feel like when people go through
something terrible assuming you didn't
like hurt someone maybe he said
something we did something that you
don't um then regret that either you
were right or like whatever but she's
not Harvey Weinstein she is you know her
own person she's her own person and she
committed her own crimes sure but I
think the most important thing to do
after you apologize and take time it's
to get back to work and the work that
she is doing and the dresses everyone is
making these days the ugliest [ __ ] like
clothing right now I would have bought
anything for my after party or anything
for amfAR and what some designers are
there some designers who are doing
incredible work but there's so much
garbage out there and she makes
beautiful feminine dresses like and
she's the only one doing it mr Kaizen no
day is Adhan for a ball gown at an
affordable price point and I just I
respect like her she's letting her works
she's not being a public figure you know
she's in the shadow controversy aside
the prettiest dress always wins right
and you know what she like she's raising
her family she's leaving Harvey's doing
her thing I'm not making my wedding
episode recap about Harvey minding their
words Georgina Chapman because I
really give a [ __ ] yeah but she's making
constantly the most beautiful dresses
this is a very hard work and talent is
rewarded this is a very interesting
question and maybe a little you know
maybe make you emotional do the American
and Italian campers crash the wedding
yes and you know who made a big splash
the Italian camper she was at the
after-party hugging her counselor and if
you hear
did you watch Betty's video where I'm
hugging Margot and then I take the mic
then I think was remix in that song
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo so there was like a
bum bum bum and I'm like what do I pack
for the scam oh my god do-do-do-do hey
what was dumped so funny they were both
there and counselors Mitch was there and
I was just so happy to have them all and
they were really getting along and
that's all I put a bass wear for my
wedding um we got a lot of questions
about like the coverage on social media
and people want to know like if you got
discounts for like like all the vendors
that you worked with like you blew up on
social media like do you get paid for
that I don't get paid for it but you get
discounts for it there is like this
trade barter relationship in any
industry but also in the wedding and I
feel like most in the wedding industry
like my wedding was like 70%
you could also say in the fashion
industry people get free clothes yeah
how's that no but LED wedding they
really value because so many people like
if you're booking a caterer or if you're
booking a band like you go check
Instagram like if they have normal
pictures like it says a lot so like the
bridal industry is really like hell-bent
on social media so like they do a lot
like I feel like everyone who gets
married on TV like even The Bachelor
weddings but also like Katie and Tom
like that then you got blown up like
they get serious discounts yeah and so
all a lot of the vendors that we worked
with like our very social friendly
vendors and they you know they obviously
saw the opportunity and doing my wedding
especially births who does like now all
of our events and they're [ __ ]
incredible so it's just we have great
relationships so that really does you
know help with the price tag because the
wedding industry is very social Warren
you know they they did you they did you
justice
yeah what were you most stressed out
about like the whole leading up to
leading up to I was really stressed out
about like you know I'm working on this
planners working on this Josh is working
on this like people are working on all
these different things and how is it
going to come together it's like did we
did we tie all of the loose ends
is everyone communicating like so I
could joke before like is our wedding
gonna be fire festival we're gonna be
nothing there you know I think everyone
feels that
you know you but it's like people who
work in the wedding industry they're
like they don't need to go over than my
new shed they do multiple weddings a
week it's like I don't need to discuss
how we're gonna walk people from
cocktail they're gonna figure it out
like right for you it's your first
wedding you're like well if every
details not sorted out well but then no
one's gonna know where to go right and I
didn't get like so chefs not every
people except I know I'm like people
know where that's [ __ ] you go and eat
it they don't they'll figure it out but
it's just like how are things gonna come
together I hadn't no real like clue but
once the wedding weekend started like we
checked into the pier on Friday and like
because we had our Shabbat dinner Friday
night there and once I got to that hotel
which if you've never been it is so
beautiful and like just elegant New York
and the plaza wishes yeah the plaza is
just if they're so different the plaza
is like you know touristy and big and
grand and the Pierre is just like
low-key and beautiful and timeless and
elegant or Gucci and it smells amazing
yeah it's and like once I got there on
Friday like everything washed away yeah
like they gave me such a beautiful room
like I just felt so like safe and a
piece there and like that and so I was
really able to enjoy the weekend like
anything that was going on for example
like our cocktail napkins we have them
show to our apartment and I thought I I
thought we brought the box with us to
the Pierre but it turned out it's just
to be more mint so they're somewhere in
our lobby because you don't even have
our cocktail napkins
I said cocktail napkins that weren't
like our custom logo or whatever yeah
they were oh really
yeah well someone said they didn't come
I was like okay then they're in our
lobby and it's not a big deal the show
will go on this is a great question
Monet 95 the next morning Margo posted a
story of Jackie in bed how come you
didn't stay with Zac on the wedding
night okay it's confusing question I did
stay with Zac on the wedding night we
had a huge suite one master suite and
then one with two beds that was
considered Theo's room and you and us
snitch that stayed there the whole good
were but then snitch was [ __ ]
partying till the break of dawn and
everyone had left and I didn't want her
to go home so late so I gave her a key
to the room I was like you can stay in
that extras room because Zack and I were
like already asleep because she was just
being out being a snitch and then he
left in the morning to go to brunch so I
crawled into the other bed and then it
looks like I just woke tup there but I
didn't so Margo would say your spell
your wedding night with you technically
she was in the room the room the room
was huge it was like an apartment
yeah um talk about the fortnight what
was strategy did you fortnight to others
fortnight did you feel embarrassed what
you for tonight it under the chuppah I
for tonight it under the chuppah I for
tonight it as we were signing our Co to
ban marriage license and then I Fortin I
did the night away but not as much as he
would think it wasn't overwhelming the
amount of it was contagious and everyone
was fortnight it it's a contagious move
and it's funny cuz like I was watching
like there were so many like parents and
like in terms of guests like it was a
very large wedding Ivana being like 350
people which wasn't his it was a big
wedding but it felt like small because
everyone's on the dance floor we were
just like packing it in yep anyways
there were so many adults and like all
these like Dallas families and like all
these parents I saw watching me and they
were laughing cuz like that's what their
kids do yeah total into a day so kids
know what it is because it's my number
their parents know what it is because
they're always doing it so everyone it
was a contagious move but it didn't I
didn't feel like I spent too much of the
Nightfort knighting and then I'm gonna
regret it like like what someone was
doing a prayer under the chuppah that
had a little beat I had a little beat
like fended Marina yeah and I throw it
up you know how did you decide decide
who to invite in terms of like famous
people was Rachel Lindsay invited no so
okay I I wanted to keep it my guest list
was probably like a third of the overall
guests in the end and I really didn't
know because I also didn't know who you
know you never know who's in New York
right ready has plans so I just invited
the same people that had been to your
wedding and they were because like we
love her we're just like it's ATPG but
he's in Columbia yeah and just like
people that I thought would be happy to
be there and it would be able to come
you know yeah and like or in New York
like Korean basically lives in New York
yes she looked so good by the way God
the two of them are so cute I never just
like a wet Bobby did you yes I saw
Amanda in the bathroom for like one
second and I was like where's Bobby
she's a common sight to meet him but
like you know I just I got lost in the
magic of it all and didn't get to see
him I'm like you think he's like easy to
spot cuz he's a giant yeah what was
going through your mind before walking
down the aisle oh um I was like thinking
I kind of have to pee but I don't want
to get out of my dress but then am I
gonna spend the whole ceremony
having to pee which I didn't I forgot
about it I was really just like anxious
to go I was excited like everyone was
walking down and everyone was seeing
everything I didn't
anything I'm the time come on get me in
there pillion coach I'm ready
afterparty was it a DJ or a playlist DJ
but it was Ben's playlist have requested
songs Ben might as well hooked up his
phone he it was all spent on saying you
know what I was glad because I know Zach
won in TV rap I wanted to be house music
Avicii and best one in 90s and so Ben
got his way cuz he was telling DJ what
to do
did you have time to enjoy any of the
delicious food yes I did so right after
the ceremony ended we were whisked back
upstairs to do our ye clewd room which
is 8 minutes where the couple is alone
no one else there's two witnesses
outside the door to make sure no one
goes in or I'm supposed to consummate
that yeah I mean that was what it was
intended for originally but now it's
just you know everyone always says you
should take some time after the ceremony
be with your husband or your wife and
that is actually part of the Jewish
tradition that you have to do that so
the wedding doesn't come we did that and
the PR like setup so nicely there was
all of this food and drinks for us we
ate so much up there like I literally
ate everything cuz also all of my
dresses mostly we're like tight on top
loose on bottom and where I really carry
all my baby food weight is in my lower
pouch or as you know someone on
Instagram many affectionately referred
to it as my Fupa
but all my dresses were very super
friendly so I actually was able to eat
as much as I wanted however I had to
stop eating at certain points because I
was dancing so hard I thought I was
gonna throw up yeah so we ate a lot in
the food room then I came down we saw
some people got the tail end of cocktail
hour that's where I saw like Amanda and
Curran I wouldn't have see I didn't seen
them all the rest at night and I got to
see like a bunch of people down there
took some shots and then we came out to
the greatest show and then that went
straight into the hora which was [ __ ]
wild and like when I'm at other people's
hores I'm like the Energizer run in Fort
knighting doing wishing doing it up and
so for my horror like I was I had to
have even more energy because I was
everyone was constantly making circles
around yes Illinois they were so big I
kept finding myself in the middle of
dance circles and you can't disappoint
no so by the end of the hora and then
like I was up in the chair and I get I
haven't been in a chair since my Bat
Mitzvah no it's a wild ride up there
it's a wild ride and I was like I was
[ __ ] going crazy at the one point is
called hot and cold Carla and then
I forget um what's that song you know
where was I whatever they when they were
like yeah we shall die and then I was a
conductor Oh chair with an apple and I'm
sure you were just enjoying sitting down
oh that too and I was also trying to
hold on everyone's like lean back but I
was like no but you really gotta lean
back you could fall off it's very
dangerous in there yeah it was but so I
was just living it up for my hora
Michael Strahan dance the hora was Zach
okay which was the best city I've ever
seen you know as a female I I don't
really like I know Michael Strahan more
from the Kelly Ripa of it all but from
the morning show host cemetery and as a
morning show host I respect other
morning shows but like you don't
understand how like every person in the
room respects I started every boy in the
room respects the [ __ ] out of Michael
Strahan and he was there why because
he's a friend of Zach's family and he
was like in the same car dancing I
didn't see him because he girls anyways
and separately for the justice simcha
dancing in the beginning and so Ben was
like he got in there and then I saw a
video and he really did get it there
yeah he was down and out he it was great
and then we have to talk about the media
of it all because we have two major
moments one the next morning Michael
Strahan mentions your wedding on GMA
right epic epic to survive a toaster
called in to watch raccoons live and I
have to say so eloquently and quickly
usually like boo and people console
watch I was live and they [ __ ] up it's
so awkward but she got like this ready
her name was Kelly she goes hi Andy
Mazel Tov on your beautiful baby
congrat Mazel Tov to Jackie and Zach on
their wedding my question is for Kim
like it was seamless he's listing this
and I still don't know who it was who
did Kelly dodge Kelly dodge yeah not
Kelly John
oh my god when I saw that I was just
like exact and I were freaking out we
watched it again last night Andy's face
he's so confused cuz he said she said
Jackie oh and Zach's so like if I were a
me I would be like Jackie Onassis right
he had something to do with leave as
well he just passed away right so he was
rightfully confused and we were just
dying that was just like the cherry on
top of a million other cherries of the
perfect Sunday of an evening
why is that Instagram I'm private for
such a like a thirsty public what a
thirsty couple yeah um thirsty wise I'm
I'm happy too for a thirst monster but
like I catch new powers he's always been
in private he doesn't accept anyone he
has like 300 followers he doesn't post
like
much but yeah he doesn't he use his
Instagram more he thought was like a
thousand people who like he just loves
the creativity of Instagram but he
doesn't use it to be a thirst monster
and you know it's it's funny that he
married a thirst monster considering
he's a pretty private guy but every once
in a while he likes to thirst it up with
me let's talk about the jewel The Jewel
the jewel was like a big big feature at
my wife he's like an accessory you
should've gone to blinged out one I know
I should have been sponsored by jewel
because people were tooling out my
wedding I and I spotted a jewel in the
wild and I was like that's what I need
right now because I don't want to drink
more but I want to just you know you
know get a little light-headed and lose
my buzz yeah jewel see jewel get your
gavel no it's like that button that
staples button jewel do you want to lose
your voice would be like ship at having
a good time and look cool jewel um but I
actually didn't lose my voice and anyway
so everyone was drooling and it was just
it was the perfect accessory for a night
cuz it's just so fun and funny and it
also gets you it takes your buzz and it
turns it up a little bit and that's just
what I want to excited I want to be
drinking too much um have you guys
decided you spoke last week about a
potential mini-moon location TBD yeah I
don't even want to go on a mini mean
because like I would rather lay in bed
and then we're going to Utah oh okay so
it's just you might be here all week
yeah we're not doing a show on Friday
but well say Thursday I'll be here yeah
I just I can okay like I mean I can't
believe I'm here today you guys you
don't even know you don't even know how
I feel um did Theo stay for the
reception
no so Theo came for pictures and he was
a [ __ ] precious gem of a man
throughout he was only needed for two
minutes it was two minutes of pure
perfection and joy and like the
picture-taking process during the
wedding is the most stressful part of
the day I could agree that you know that
hour the two hours before the wedding
where it's like family's all different
combinations cousins etc and it's
[ __ ] stressful as hell and Theo and
Anthony Vasquez and Juan really made it
as seamless impossible it's like he came
at the perfect time where I needed to
pick me up
I needed a hit of the Tigs and I got it
and also so Anthony Vasquez um the
company took all of my photos and they
sent Juan their photographer who was
just like I'm we're gonna love him
totally got me one on a level of I have
no [ __ ] patience for people and you
on a level of I don't want cheesy bridal
photos with a dark background in me
looking somber
I want pop I want dynasty I want the
cover of Gossip Girl editorial looking
editorial fashion this is a commercial
non-commercial get me on a carriage in
Central Park like this is for Instagram
this is not like Oh totally I hate those
wedding pictures but I can only look at
you and dip so many times even though we
we crush the dip but like I can't I
could only do the so many times like I
want and he just [ __ ] got me we were
tearing through New York and like I
couldn't have gotten more beautiful
looking day it was stunning out it was
cold but like same gentleman kept me up
and during Zach nice first look the
sunlit area came out and the Sun is on
me and I have like sunlit photos it was
so crazy
where I was leaving it was raining yeah
brain looks start snowing at 8 o'clock
um this is such a good question were
there any wedding crashers not that I
know of we had tight security I wasn't
aware of the security apparatus but I
know that we had security that was
organized through our wedding planner
and he had said like they will have
guest list no one is getting in or out
on the list when I was in rehearsal
Mikey your wedding planner came up to me
he was like do we know someone named
Joseph Cohen and I'm like of course we
did that's like obviously that's a name
that I know and then I'm like okay
Joseph Cohen no and then I'm like let me
check Jackie's seating list because you
had emails at us he's like no he's not
on the list so I'm like oh so no so I
guess that's like the only crasher but
it feels like he definitely was invited
Joseph Cohen no that I don't know that
name but that's just such a name of
someone we would know right but maybe he
that's why he used that name to get in
what was your um method when it came to
bridesmaids dresses and did anyone show
up in the color yes Nicole Berkman
showed up in the color and she's an
honorary bridesmaid because I [ __ ]
love her I never got her because she
lives in LA it's like how can I ask
someone to be a bridesmaid that I
haven't seen in a year right but he was
so [ __ ] apt that she wore the color
because she is a bridesmaid the
bridesmaid dresses worked out so
perfectly I just asked all the girls I
was very casual and very cavalier about
it I was like uh I went through a few
different colors because um the color
scheme of our wedding kept changing and
I want to talk about the decorum what
ended up being but for a while we were
doing like an M well my invitations
which I'm gonna do an imitation
unveiling this week because I'm so proud
of them and now I can show you all the
details they were done by by invitations
she didn't know I absolutely love her
she is part-time invitations part-time
therapist yeah
and she says that she was like people
come in here and it's like you know all
the different like families and politics
and it's like it's literally family
Feller therapy even trying to figure out
how to put people's make like family's
names online so I was like and I always
went by myself every time so I was just
enjoying it but she was just made me
feel so much better about everything and
like at one point we were standing out
so many invitations they just never made
me feel like one like what I was asking
for was crazy and to like I had this
idea like this Tiffany box invitation
which I will show you guys soon and she
just like she got it done oh my god
there's so much and her office is in her
house like she lets you in turn her home
but also into her heart and it was a
came out even more beautiful than I had
imagined and like I'm just I'm so proud
of this I can't wait to share with you
guys she also did our Mints which saved
my [ __ ] oh my god wedding mints are a
thing because wedding breath is a thing
because no one's eaten all day oh my god
hide like I couldn't get enough mints I
was seeing them everywhere I was
literally guzzling them no I have like
three in my apartment like so important
so she helped me with our mints our
cocktail napkins which apparently made
their way I think they did yeah and it
was just she's great so the color scheme
kept changing and at one point I wanted
the room to be like this sky-blue
Tiffany themed but you know that can
start to be a little cheesy and done in
a certain way and I wanted my theme to
be frozen and that turned out to be what
the ballroom was was just perfect
because you are weselton of arendelle I
am weselton of arendelle and it's
February so it's like I'm not gonna have
you know a green spring wedding like and
I love the theme winter wonderland I
don't think it's played out and I
remember like the first time I saw
frozen and Elsa's castle when she goes
on the mountain and she starts shooting
herself her own shoot ice I was like I
want to get married in that castle it
said that to Josh that was like really
the only vision I ever had and he was
like he and he was like okay like yes
that's the cheezy reference but I can do
it in the classy way and he really did
and it was Vanessa Williams who was like
this is frozen and she said that to Josh
and he was like oh my god she gets she
gets the theme the Vanessa Williams of
it all and so anytime I was planning
themes it all had to come back to a
movie if I can't see it in a movie like
Olivia's wedding to me was beauty in the
beam yes like I wanted frozen or at one
point we were going to do an emerald
wedding and Josh design and was gorgeous
but I was just like this is such a
beautiful wedding for someone else it
just doesn't feel like me yeah but it
was it was Emerald City Wizard of Oz
like everything has to come back to
they like so I can envision it and then
our hippo was originally gonna be also
like winter wonderland like like uh an
isle of trees and it was just like
people I always thought that those
ceremony should match the party and Josh
was like no everything should be a new
experience people think they know what's
going on and then BAM even about
something else and finally and I had
posted that Zack and I were going to
wedding therapy because we couldn't
agree on a color much like our apartment
and finally Zack was like we can do pink
thank God and it just it was a world of
opportunity there's so many pink flowers
oh my gosh
so then Josh was telling us he's like
ability like this I thought it was gonna
be a flower wall of pink with a dome
over like with a like an L shape we arch
for the chuppah and it turned out to be
like a dome planetarium planetarium yes
pink baby's breath and I it looked like
[ __ ] it looks like we got married in
a cotton candy machine like yes oh my
god it was more beautiful than I ever
could have imagined
I can't believe shape it was so unique
like the shape the colors it was plenty
it was it was everything like it all
comes back to the we were the plains and
then the emerald green at first I just
chose emerald well at last I chose had
more green because it was the color of
the season I was seeing emerald green
dresses everywhere I was like I want you
guys to buy your own Justin I want you
to be fashion and feel beautiful and
look beautiful and not look like cheesy
bridesmaids wearing like [ __ ] chiffon
so get yourself a the emerald green
dress of your choice so when we were
doing like winter wonderland emerald
green like wasn't totally making sense
but I was like I can't change it again
I'm [ __ ] sticking right and everyone
so not only did the greens and the
Pink's in the hope of like bring out the
emerald green but everyone looks like a
million bucks and even though you really
were not specific with color we all
really showed up in the same shade it
was perfect yeah it all worked out as
like I say one as I hoped it would but
if even if one person looked wrong I
would take a picture with them and they
would be like you know what get out
you're ruining the shot you can have
this a picture with all of us for you
know like not in a rude way but it's
like you didn't like I I mean it's so
easy for you almost too easy
yep but everyone looked like perfection
I was just like so impressed I was so
impressed with my gals can you explain
the McDonald's there's a little bit of a
confusion because McDonald's not kosher
and it was a completely kosher it was
confusing it was a McDonald's it was an
up
it was a W for the wine right oh I miss
up and at one point when I was doing it
was so important to me I'm the coach
dictator made it was statement I was
when you open them there was either
chicken nuggets there was mini
hamburgers and there were French fries
cups and mini hot dogs in the McDonald's
and at one point when I was doing I was
like do you think people are gonna think
this is actually McDonald's because it
isn't kosher and then I was like nah but
I should have written somewhere on it
like you know make wine ribs or whatever
yeah but I just wanted to be authentic
and I was just going around and it was
like it's McDonald's I was so excited
about it was that was like something I
was so important to me to have was like
cool branded after-party food during
like dinner time or any downtime off the
dance floor did you go around and say
how'd everyone did you sit down two
people come to you I never went around
and said hi to everyone because like the
people the only people that I like
needed to spend time with were you know
my family members and we were at the
tables right beside me
and I saw my friends at all points
people would come up to us having the
sweetheart table which I didn't when we
first started planning I was like I
don't know if we need a sweetheart table
blah blah blah then I saw living in Zach
too and they look so cute I did the
whole time and I I can't recommend
enough to sweetheart table you guys like
I think so today having a reprieve and
it's like when you're sitting there
together like really no one's gonna
bother you when you're there alone
someone's coming yeah but uh I so I
definitely ain't got a chance to talk to
everyone at the party but I feel I feel
okay like I feel like I really got to
spend a lot of time with people do you
have any regrets ooh
also pronounced regrets honestly no not
one like because it was the perfect
night even if something went wrong like
it was just the way that it should be
like I was so perfect in the moment I
was just enjoying everything so much and
then like just watching it the next day
on everyone's stories like I I was just
so ended I didn't even care what it
looked like
do you know what I mean but then I saw
what it looked like and I was like it's
perfect like and everyone keeps using
the word fairytale and like that wasn't
even something I ever liked that wasn't
even on my mood board I'm like I want a
fairytale princess wedding but you know
what like if the shoe fits
if the glass slipper fits if the glass
slipper fits this is a great question
you get a neon sign that said the wine
rubs do you get to take that home with
you yes I'm gonna put it we're gonna put
in our apartment you know when we have
space and probably when we move but that
was something that Zach
really really wanted was in the unsigned
and we wanted this flower wall because
we wanted also a lot of opportunities
for people to take pictures and we
thought that flower wall was gonna be it
in front of the wine arms we got some
pictures there people and then we also
had the mirror mirror photo booth cuz I
was like I just want hashtags Accio to
be poppin and honestly like it's way
more popular it's so puppet than I ever
thought people are just tagging their
rash their random pictures a kale
apparently the hashtags a gala was
trending on Instagram stories that night
so it got into the feeds of everyone on
ok because that like one of Jack's
friends told me so it this hashtag was
even bigger matter but like everyone was
taking pictures in front of the Hopa in
the bridal arch there was another flower
all there were just so many photo
opportunities which is like someone who
goes to weddings for photo opportunities
was important to me so I want to talk
about a moment that was my personal
favorite moment and a moment where I
feel like not a lot of people have their
phones so maybe not everyone knows about
it but it was X performance so they got
everyone in a circle on the dance floor
and then because ok all those of you to
call his performance your personal
favorite moment in not yours no it was
my favorite moment so they got everyone
round the dance where you cut the cake
and then they move the cake out everyone
was just standing in a circle around you
and Zack was what we thought he was
gonna make a speech and then Mary I
thought so champ Mary Ann's started
playing Abby in the background I'm like
oh that's nice of Marion to give his
speech like a little rhythm rhythm and
you know Zack never drinks he was wasted
and it was amazing so there's a beat and
I'm like this is weird and I'm like wait
this sounds kind of familiar once upon a
time if US turn off your new toaster
when Jack emits act like a couple years
ago for one of like a birthday
anniversary he wrote me a country song
about the story of our love story and
how we met and Jackie loves country
music Zack is much more like R&B rap um
he likes to write songs like that but it
was it was like a cute song back then
and like I didn't appreciate it until he
literally performed it in the middle of
the circle and everyone knew the words I
didn't even remember how I knew the
words oh me oh my love like this comes
once in a lifetime that's how I know I
got my girl and I'm neck
never letting go it one joke a music
dopey it's the best thing that's
happened to me so always I'll stay
loving you forever and today was so good
and Zach really has been made the girls
called zach is DJ khaled oh my god he
has this great stage presence where he
doesn't like saying he just is like oh
me oh it was just so great and I was lit
him ding for just all of it
it was so great I loved that moment the
cake-cutting and what's so funny is I
was everyone kept asking me what's your
kid gonna look like I hadn't done
anything with my cake Burch got me a
cake from lessees cake and the tzus
desserts less he's the same on a mine
and so it's a kosher cake and he told me
he was gonna and I was like every
wedding cake is beautiful I've never
seen an ugly one and then they come
through with a seven-layer like gucci
mane frozen cake and it's in the dance
floor like towards the second half of
the wedding it's just on the day it's
it's a part of the dance floor and we'd
like the cake cutting was so beautiful
it's like I don't even plan for this and
it was just like you really have to work
with vendors that you love and trust and
that love and trust you because yeah
they will just deliver for you when you
don't even give them a slight of
direction and so like Josh like knew
what I didn't know that I wanted he got
it from lessees they made the most
beautiful cake and it was delicious too
and so that whole cake cutting moment
which I didn't even plan for and I was
like who I never even cut your cake I
didn't even see it like yeah it's
somewhere else I was like we don't need
that let's keep the party going so it
was just it was such an incredible
moment that I really hadn't planned for
then Zach started saying meanwhile I had
just gotten concussed but I'm like
that's how I was distracted because your
bands performing a country song for you
like the [ __ ] dream then Zach's dad
starts singing new york new york which
not only is like he's so incredible at
singing so but it's a major colgate song
like oh cool gate of the wedding which i
have to get it they brought it they are
just all my colgate friends and my
extended colgate friends I'm just like
[ __ ] so fun and I knew that they
would be but at the jug that which is
like the Kohli part when the jug is
closing they always play New York New
York it was towards the end of the
wedding and so everyone and I'm with my
big dress kick lining I don't know how
many people like saw my undies I don't
really care but I was no matter you're
married woman though right I just
couldn't stop kick lining we did so many
questions about the 4:19 but more so how
did your bun stay intact with the
fortnight egg oh my god I'll tell you
how my bun stayed in
act Michele Charles and love her love
her so Michele Charles did my hair for
every aspect of the ceremony chose to do
my hair for my Bat Mitzvah which like
it's just a really fun anecdote but
she's always been she's like I think
she's a person there who's known us so
long it's Marta LuAnn - yeah but I'm oh
my god I love her so much so she did my
waves and she did the flowers in my hair
which I saw someone else how did I get
the flowers so my dress was Karolina
Herrera and the wedding salon ordered me
a few extra flowers that were on the
dress just in case I wanted to put them
on my veil or something and I I was
looking for head pieces but some of them
like to be a little cheesy like I feel
you know it could be tacky Oh especially
it's not diamonds it's rhinestone so
it's like I'm wearing this you know
Couture dress and I head full of
rhinestones so I was like I want the
motif to fit but I want something in my
hair so Michele just like place them
perfectly and then I always knew that I
wanted to put my I wanted my hair up in
a bun for my wrist and if you're a big
dancer like me I think it's the best
decision I one of the best decisions
I've made in my life right up there with
marrying Zack putting my hair in a
button or because I was able to dance
and sweat and every time I'd sweat I'd
move it into the bun in the buns that's
better and I didn't have to worry about
like you know hair on my neck yeah buddy
and it looks so good with the dress I
almost wanted to wear my hair up for the
whole time it's like I my hair is so
much a part of you it's so hard on I
have such nice hair that it's like I
can't hide my hair in the ole wedding
but putting it up and then she put the
flowers back in so she put she literally
put my hair in that perfect bun that
lasted through a conclusion
she said it lasted through the
concussion because she braided your hair
and then put the braid into a bun oh my
and she did it so quickly like in during
the cocktail hour and it was so perfect
like she put the flower second which
also stayed flat
the man fell on the flowers and they
stayed so oh my god I can't kill you and
also while I'm talking about my glam my
makeup was done by Lauren Lieberman and
if you know me you know that I am so
like scared of getting my makeup done
all the time and she's the only did your
own makeup for Olivia's wedding and for
my wedding yes and Lauren is the person
who taught me how did you like you know
good makeup so I she's done my makeup a
few times in the past just to like go
out and stuff and I always love how I
look but like for my wedding it's just
so scary and she just did an incredible
job and I'm the worst person do you make
a bomb cuz I was like okay I don't want
you to put anything on but I want it to
look good and so I'm like you can't do
yeah that's us so I'm a tough but she
just like crush it and then she had to
leave because she had to get home so I
never really had a makeup touch-up I did
like a little bit of lipstick and like
added some more eyebrows but the makeup
lasted all night and I just like I felt
so beautiful I felt like myself but I
also felt like a little more elevated
than I usually look yeah cuz you don't
wanna look the same like as you do but I
also don't want to look too different
and she just like totally [ __ ]
crushed [ __ ] Lauren Lieberman if you
live in Montreal I'm jealous of that you
because you can go get your makeup done
my hair you said on the patreon one of
like the little key details you added
are you putting on a channel then let's
let's just take a minute okay you said
on the toast wanted like the little
small details you added that someone
might not notice is you told the band
when playing [ __ ] better have my money
to pay to say snitch better have my
money
did they I don't know I don't know I
think better have my money was only
played during the after-party I don't at
the end I don't remember but that was a
good question I don't remember there
were a few other details I remember
people are asking me that I couldn't
share oh I wanted to share my custom
cocktails did you see them at the course
I did they were so cute okay so and
that's a good question cuz a lot of
people want to know how you like did
something special to honor daddy's
memory okay so one thing that I really
wanted to do is we had custom cocktails
and our dad used to always order the
same drink I never heard him order
anything else it was just greggers on
the craters on the rocks with a twist so
I had a drink at my cocktail hour called
the Big O which was his nickname yeah
yeah which was his nickname that he gave
himself yeah like he really was the Big
O like his boat was the big Oh
everything was a big oh he made his own
merch that said the big guy yeah that
you think no entrepreneur no checking
now I know where we get our
entrepreneurial spirit from so
everything that was him was just the big
out so the drink was called the Big O
and honestly it's the best thing to
order if you just want straight vodka
it's basically a shot but like classier
right and so we had the Big O we had the
Jackie O which is you know my custom
cocktail that's award-winning and that
she invented at a bartending class and
won a contest for it in the class so
it's just like cucumbers lime basil
simple syrup deliciousness and vodka
deliciousness obscene and in there was I
think a Moscow memes which was a Moscow
Mule but with tequila instead of vodka
because we didn't want three things this
is a good question that might be cheaper
so feel free to say no but a lot of
people wanted to know because
you know everyone was obviously filming
my performance and I performed coming
home from Country Strong we can't
believe it's taking you an hour you
think that this is a hard episode for me
okay so just like I'm just trying not to
make it all about myself which I'm very
self-conscious these days of like not
making things about other people about
myself
so I thought I would wait and just like
didn't want to get okay but I really
want to talk about it because I watched
Prince John say you know Ben has never
seen it and he loved it max never seen
Ben loved it I get not enough people
I've seen it and I just like there are
so many celebrities are you running but
it's important that Gwyneth Paltrow
Instagram story your wedding I it is
important so that song coming home is
just our favorite song we love that
movie Country Strong we used to watch it
all the time growing up and that song is
just like such a great song but also
great message like we're there we are
very like home and family-oriented and I
have to say I think the rabbi nailed you
but your person he nailed your vibe in
the wedding because what he said he was
like when I was talking to you you were
trying to explain like see you met with
the rabbi like four or five times before
the wedding I'm just trying to get to
know like you and Zak as a couple you
and your family and you were trying to
explain to him like steamy vibes and and
he got it and he was like but what it
all comes down to it was like you're so
obsessed with your family and I was like
that's so true it's like all these weird
things Jackie does like Stevie vibes
whatever like that's family and I
thought he just nailed who you were to a
tee and I loved like coming home is the
song that's what it's all about yeah
we're all tried to break me I found a
road to take me home it's like at the
end of the day whatever happens in
outside world is what it is but like
home family like that's what matters
it's so true and so the way that this
performance came to be is I was taught
why I was thinking about for my first
dance with my mom like what song I'm on
to you we have a few songs that we loved
and this was on the roster and then once
I decided I wanted to be the song I was
like no one this is one of the songs
that you sing incredibly well like no
one that I know sings this song better
than you so it's like I wouldn't have
you know any of the band people sing it
would be like if don't rain on my parade
was was playing at the wedding and you
weren't singing it I mean that would
just be like insulting right so it's
like if coming home is playing you're
singing it and it's like I do want you
to perform at my wedding and it's like
if mom and I are dancing and you're
singing and it's just like that would
just be so beautiful well I have to say
that was so kind of you because you know
as a huge attention [ __ ] like I just I
loved it I loved the attention I just
loved like the videos I just loved it so
thank you for letting me be a part of it
but what everyone wanted to know because
everyone was videoing me say
and there's a moment that everyone
seemed to have gotten on camera where
mom says something to you and you start
crying
do you want to Sharon I honestly don't
know what she said in that moment but
you know obviously like what we were
just talking about that I'm and what's
funny is I was like crying and like I
have this like cute sad cry when I was
really happy and the I did I cried like
that at my Bat Mitzvah I remember we
were like all dancing at the end of the
night it was like um the four of us our
mom and our dad and I was just crying
because I was so happy and there's this
like picture of me like crying and I and
I made everyone else cry because I was
so happy and that's how I was crying
when we were dancing together and she
was like you're just like how you were
at your about it so kandi was like
saying these things like you know about
daddy I'm just like it was just like so
beautiful and then this song that's
playing it's like you have your bunkers
and like people were asking why you gave
the middle finger and it's like it
wasn't the middle finger to anyone in
the room it's just to like to the world
yeah you can all not the people watching
right now not two people are in the room
but the rest of you can go [ __ ]
yourselves
seriously um did you give a wedding
favors no the McDonald's the McDonald's
there were flip-flops the souffles did
you bastards like did I oh my god Jackie
the souffle no I mean dessert I couldn't
keep me there was a man serving souffles
that were chocolate and I took the
souffle and there was peanut butter and
jelly inside and I want to say like I
needed to sit down because I was I
literally get six pounds I can only had
one it was a gooey coming out I was like
what is this souffle it was crack
cocaine oh my god that is so I like it's
not even like I didn't have time she and
I actually did eat main course cuz I
really wanted to try the short rib it
was good but it was like the more I ate
like the more I felt I wouldn't be able
to dance like I wasn't like I just did
not stop dancing the whole night like
wherever no matter the opportunity dad
so you see when I was with my friends
and they took my dress and they were
like being like could I see I started
that oh wow well thing of course that's
my favorite thing to do weddings and
when they play firework oh my god they
put Mary Ann play firework which is one
of my favorite songs and they had the
fireworks going off and it was just like
[ __ ] fire
truly what do you plan to do with your
wedding dresses so I'm gonna have them
clean and preserved I might wear the
second if I get a made a tamper I'm
[ __ ] wearing this
do it I'm getting my [ __ ] picture
taken no I'm getting your money's worth
right and then my wedding dress I mean
that is just like a piece of history I
will have the preserve and if the
opportunity everywhere to present itself
to wear it again I would love to
otherwise I just want to keep it in the
museum of my home would you share your
wedding playlist I don't have a wedding
playlist no look would you make a
playlist of like your song go to songs
like you're so happy you played or you
just don't want to mad a job know what
those were I didn't even care what songs
were playing I was enjoying like I
wasn't like oh I didn't ask for this
song or where's that song I wanted I was
just like whatever Mary Ann's playing H
the song to be played did you in Maine's
exchange presence
yeah we didn't in the room just like we
exchanged notes and like a little
present and I got my um my official
wedding band because in Jewish
ceremonies you can't wear any diamonds
under the chuppah so the wedding band
that he put on me in the ceremony is
just a plain silver band Platinum and
fancier and then I was like you know and
I'll get like a wedding band that
matches my ring eventually but he got it
for me that night and so now I have like
a nice you know Real Housewife hand it's
just like when it's like more stacked um
and then I just wanted to say something
about my ceremony because obviously I
only saw for my perspective but and
everyone keeps asking me like what were
the highlights of the night and
obviously you singing to me and mom was
a highlight my dance the sack I was was
a highlight the twirl but standing under
the ceremony my ceremony was probably
about 40 minutes from start to finish
he's so concise he's the rabbi who did
my ceremony rabbi slim Nicky he was my
teacher in high school and he's just
like I know he's the principal of our
high schools like we have a connection
to her principal right no one's getting
sent to the principal office now no no
they're not
so he really took a lot of time to get
to know Zach and I and our ceremony was
very traditional Modern Orthodox but you
know not about a lot of our guests are
so everything that he did he explained
in English like the meaning of it and
you know what it means in turn in terms
of the order of how we're getting
married and it loves up you know so
everyone really I feel like I mean I
didn't talk to anyone but I imagine they
felt like they knew what was going on
even when it became a Hebrew heavy heavy
or Aramaic heavy like he and I would
just remember standing under the chuppah
and it was 40 minutes so I was really
present like every other moment goes by
in a second
song is three minutes like I was
standing under there for 40 minutes I
was really able to like be present and
be like oh my goodness like I am
marrying Zack in front of the people
that I love the most in this world under
a cloud of pink like I'm in heaven this
is what heaven looks like is heaven is
anywhere like that is not that
planetarium of pink is my idea of heaven
and planetarium it was just that was
when I was like this is so beautiful I
was able to really soak it in so like I
just so enjoyed my ceremony I don't know
how other people experienced it the same
way but I hope that it was good and then
I was glad that announcement was made
after not to spoons yes cuz that's so
tacky when people are like yeah me too
and you know some grandpa has this sound
on yeah oh my god um this is maybe my
favorite question was there anyone like
a guest who was really annoying you know
cuz there was one who's annoying me and
I'll tell I'll tell you about her later
I mean there always is yeah yeah there
were people who are annoying me but it
was out of love so I wasn't that annoyed
they're just annoying me with their love
how annoying can that be
did mames know you were gonna change
your outfits um yes he he did have a
clue yeah but he didn't know like this
scale and he definitely didn't know that
the second dress was almost even bigger
than the first dress we were where that
hashtag Zakia was breaking the Internet
while you were at your what I had no
clue but I also didn't realize was I
told burst I'll you know as long as
don't post anything like during the
ceremony until after I've already posted
and after it's done because I want us
all to be present but then it was like
an afterthought like you could freely
post whatever you want and then I was
watching Josh Burgess story and Josh was
saying like this was the first time a
bride barely let us like post her
wedding why that I didn't know that was
like a new thing and I'm honestly so
glad because the toasters have given us
so much and are always there for us and
always support us and like and I
honestly I would have I I would have
invited you all if I could have and I'm
just putting you did and I'm so glad
that you were all able and it wasn't
just like everyone getting bits and
pieces and getting scraps of what they
get I'm trying to figure out what's
going on like I'm so glad you guys were
able to feel like you were there because
like I wish you could have been because
we love you so so much and I'm I'm so
glad I was able to do that or that Burch
was able to do that I'm from everyone
stories and Mikey stories like that
people felt like they were there because
I wish he could have been how many
drinks did you end up happening having
over the course of the night ooh so I
didn't I'm trying to think if I drank at
all before
walked down the I think I had a little
bit of champagne we all took a shot
after oh yeah sign the ketubah so I had
had one shot and then throughout the
night I was only drinking shots because
I didn't want like the want anything to
make me tired or anything not that
really anything kind of so I probably
had about six shots over the course of
the night I actually think my level of
drunk was perfect it's exactly what I
wanted and it's like if I ever wanted to
get crazy I would have drank more but
it's like if I can't have fun relatively
sober at my own wedding like when we're
than you so but it was a perfect Zack
was so drunk it was amazing no it's only
amazing cuz he really like never gets
drunk and when he does he just like goes
home but he had to stay because it was
his wedding right and then for the
after-party which was just wild madness
people like dancing on tables and it
turned into a club all this fog and it
was crazy Zack got on the mic someone
gave him my key turned into an emcee it
was so fun and seeing the whole night
and I'm just up there dancing and
twirling and having that and kick lining
and he's and seeing and like shallow
came on and he's like you know he's just
being a height man he was like raisins
were having a good time whoo and the
child comes down he's like raise your
hands for you're shallow everyone's like
it was so funny honey sorry I was just
enjoying your story I didn't find
another question but let me ask you this
what did you eat the next day not enough
because I was crippled by my head so I
woke up there was a brunch the next
morning that I couldn't attend because
my head was the concussion of it all so
an attack actually want to bring me up
some food but I didn't enjoy it then
Margo Bloom brought me a better tip
Rihanna cake which I didn't have a
chance to eat and I had some Pringles
and then I didn't eat until I got home
that night at 7 o'clock and I ordered
sarahfey and I had two slices of
margherita pizza like a person or the
surfing the shoes he had some pasta but
I got full so quickly because like I
guess like because my stomach has been
so small and then I just passed out so I
still have more pots in the fridge
literally all I'm doing today is eating
because today I can finally enjoy food
video Agra fer
what do you what do you plan
strategically socially on delivering
some premium video content I have to see
the videos first but honestly
patreon.com slash mornings are totally
for that like they're going to
those you know those three department
clips lips and you know it is so private
and it's not even like I'm trying to
thirst out like for subscribers which
you know I know them but it's more so
like I don't want like the world is so
cruel and rude and annoying and like
even on a perfect moment they'll find
some [ __ ] to take apart and it's like
the people who are our patreon
subscribers like most I would say 99%
you know there's still one person who
subscribed out of hate and at that point
your fan base bitterly pained to see our
shed so you don't know if it you're a
fan but you guys just you love us and I
feel safe posting that sort of stuff
with you as opposed to just opening it
up to the world just asking for for
disgust ya know who do you think is a
better emcee Zach or Lisa Rinna oh my
god great question and you know what the
next day I was thinking like wow Zach
was being Lisa Rinna I should have said
get on the [ __ ] table and dance Andy
Cohen paid for your lies and then I was
like I didn't even realize but it was
Andy Cohen's bridal shower literal and
it wasn't even like I was trying me that
having once I would have said that but
it was uh so funny to me Zach is a
better MC oh so he didn't insult
everyone saying that you know we have no
like it wasn't for Andy Cohen we got a
lot of questions about the half-brother
of it all a lot of people didn't know we
have a half-brother so our brother Jaden
and by the way he lives in on the west
coast in San Diego so we don't see him a
lot which is why people don't know that
we actually have a half-brother but he
comes to every like every time he's
invited to an event he hops on a plane
which is like a lot of work and
expensive flights so it is much
appreciated and so usually it's a major
event like a wedding doesn't happen that
often but we had just seen him at
Olivia's weigh like one month it's like
we got to see him so soon after and like
he's just so funny and just such a great
valu admits oh he's just so fun to see
him and it's so funny I'm sure for the
toasters because we're just like the
scenes and we're all girly but like we
have a half-brother
yeah and he's really the best Emmett I
love him and I'm so glad he was able to
come and he brought a date who was like
the nicest girl ever you know it oh my
god wait did you watch the show
strucker's Instagram story no I didn't
even see Tyler struck renewed see there
no my god okay so Taylor's trekker has
his Instagram story where she's like
wait til the end because you see me just
being drunk making friends so she's like
filming the room when everyone's walking
in she's like oh man it's so beautiful
and at the very end she runs into our
half brother David's date and she at the
very end of the video you could hear her
saying you look like Selena Gomez oh my
god that is so it was so funny okay I
really feel like I got through oh oh my
god we got this question a lot and this
is a great place to end are you gonna
change your Instagram handle or like
what are you gonna do socially for your
new name
Jackie why not I'll definitely change my
facebook name I don't know about
Instagram yet but I I'm my name on
Instagram is and jackassery it's Jackie
oh and I'm still Jackie oh that's like
my stage name now yeah so but I think
like I'm gonna change I'm definitely
changing Facebook see Jackie Winer I'm
pretty sure I changed my name legally
when I got married at the courthouse
like I opted in for them really yes so
um yeah I'm gonna see like where where
it takes me that way I just want to make
sure I hit on everything so it was like
just so much that I wanted to say about
the evening what deodorant did you wear
I was sweating like up night pig we made
Olivia go out and buy clinical deodorant
because like my deodorant was not
cutting it I brought many I brought all
my sin birds and I had them in my
collection they were under my table and
everyone was using but everyone thought
it was crazy
Sam bird was made for Zakir oh it was
made for just like weddings like you in
your little et parker judith lieber
clutch like what do you there's nothing
to fit I can't even fit a lipstick you
can't put your phone you guys
november/december does a monthly
subscription service that we use here at
the Cho's they send you every month
miniature sized up like Kuch Kuch a--
brand perfumes and they're not even that
mini because they'd like 120 sprays they
should last you a month and you can get
um new ones every month so if you want
to like stay with the same scent you
were looking you oh you know I did some
porn and you know what I got and I was
like why do I know this smell candy my
product didn't used to wear that I
scored in college I worked your wets my
junior year that's what I was spraying
at my wedding so if you guys want an
exclusive offer for our listeners you
can get 50% off your first month of
scent bird for only seven dollars and
fifty cents of your for your first
fragrance go to scent bird comm slash
toast
use our code toast for 50% off your
first month that's scent bird SC ent BIR
d.com slash toast
no it truly say my life yeah they always
saved my life but I actually I felt like
I smells good in between that in the
mints I think I made it okay considering
I like wasn't eating and only drinking
actually did eat but still my wrath is
just deadly from Iquitos season overall
even hear something crazy I mean I drank
a ton and I was like out like dancing
and sweating I didn't have one sip of
water yesterday because we had no water
in our house that is great
and I just had a cup of water for the
first time and I'm having like crazy dry
mouth also feel posted the sweetest
thing and like Zach was really touched
by it but you know what Theo did do that
I was really upset with him um yeah he
posted the unfazed student photo whereas
I had just posted the face change photo
so like that's highly embarrassing I'm
glad nobody pointed it out but I need to
be the first one to point it out just in
case anybody else does end up on celeb
face like would that be the worst thing
they know you always say that you're
like I'm I want to be on celeb face they
get like low-level bloggers on there
put me on let me in coach right so maybe
this is we're baiting them like look at
it difference it's just like I took my
hip in a little like velvet I'm sorry
it's an unforgiving fabric and I had to
how did you feel about being a side
parts team you know what now I'll ask
you actually now I want to know your
thoughts this is how I felt about being
a side parts teen um I got I kept
getting it retouched like before my
singing and just and in the first like
30 minutes after the retouching I was
like living old Hollywood glamour like
yes Brigitte Bardot but then like you
know a couple dances a couple drinks
like the sweaty you know the thing came
down and it was very I was that meme of
the llama being like mom you really need
to focus on my art right now like I
looked so emo in some pictures and so
like it was definitely brave I don't
know if I would do it again or maybe I
would do it again in a dress I felt more
comfortable and like the dress I kept
like tugging at like um I don't know it
was I'm glad I did it and there was
definitely some glamorous photos but
there definitely some not so glamorous
oh it was so guys I want to say for your
song like not only did you sound amazing
and it was like just so special but you
also we're doing like cabaret when you
were like a mansion on a hill here's
hoping no I mean nobody likes my job
like I had pride planned on doing that
joke okay so the part of the song goes
like this um it's a four-letter word a
place you go to heal your hurt it's an
altar it's a shelter one place you're
always welcome a pink flamingos
double-wide one-bedroom in a high-rise a
mansion on a hill here's hoping because
it's like all the different types of no
one was listening and then at the end oh
that was great that like when you just
it was literally you were a countess
LuAnn no I was careless
it was a cab or less it was so funny you
definitely sold we were okay we were
also being so funny and thirsty anytime
we had the micro like morning toast I
mean there's so many people in the room
might as well not only that there's so
many people from Dallas I added a second
show in Dallas at the rehearsal dinner
don't take it I need us
and at the right after my performance um
buddy thank you guys I'll be here on I
take it's available i girl thorough job
calm because there are all these people
from dallas maybe they know i'm gonna
show maybe they don't i added a second
choice the majestic theatre tickets are
available at girls no job calm and they
just thought they would want to know we
weren't really using that shameless self
promo
we were but i mean if not then when no
total so the the wedding was a talent
show like the whole time someone was
performing at all times but like that's
it and you know what it was and it was
the exact same thing that goes down at
camp toast but no matter what happened
it ends all end up dancing and singing
around a microphone and like it was just
like black-tie camp toast but that was
the vibe so if you went to camp toaster
you're going like it'll just be more
zakir oh and it really makes you realize
like growing up like when we were in
like middle school we went to bomb it
suppose like every weekend and it was
like lit open bar but like when you're a
kid like you can't even appreciate a bar
mitzvah like the parents must've been
having so much fun because it was like
every night like a different country
club hotel like we'll be recapping our
kids bar mitzvahs wait just like this
speaking of country clubs you guys
you're gonna die so i'm i something's
going on with my voicemail where it's
not giving me that annoying notification
that it always does and then someone
left me a boy saw that i had to go check
and i saw that i had six voicemails
including one from a random 5.6 number
from someone at sea wayne saying that
our membership has been withdrawn no
they said they're not gonna take us on
as new members please withdraw your
membership like how do you even do that
i sent an application via email and the
email no it was just like you have to
like make us statement like resigning we
definitely blew them up like a little
too much over here like their private
and they don't want to be like
associative it's like these thirst
monsters but like are you kidding me
like aren't it's country clubs in the
decline isn't this like you know like
you should be so lucky
seriously like that really pissed me off
and so many color comes reach out to us
like we would love to have you and me
like no we're waiting for see main it's
our childhood know we were like wearing
a chastity belt and see wayne held the
kid and you know what eat it look we had
our brought me we don't need to go to
see Wayne anymore because it's out of
our legacy box we can go back to all
these open really going that we were
going for the most part to this country
club to like relive our childhood our
childhood and like our bat mitzvahs were
there and like it's just like it's we
grew up with our dad there like it was
really like a special thing that day now
ruined thank you kenny was your name who
left them lovely voicemail
I wish I remember your last name because
I'd blow you up and we found out that
your daughter's a toaster but whatever
sorry I had to what we're saying I'm
sorry they're just like relive the
memories but now we have legacy box
which if you don't know what legacy box
is it's the answer to all of your
questions if I want to watch these old
home movies and seem a little picture
old many VCR videos like we can't watch
even my Bat Mitzvah which is a DVD is
not tried and habitable whatever these
who has a DVD player anymore no legacy
boxes a craziest thing I do this box
they send you a box in the mail an empty
box where you put all of your old crap
in videotape you see our 3ds
you could put all cameras films etc
memories they take all of it and they
put it on digital USBs and memory cards
for you so that you can have it forever
and now that we have that and not only
to be high but we have a promo code for
you obviously but we don't need to see
mine we have the legacy that's like one
of those companies that like I can't
believe I didn't think of because that's
like a worldwide problem compatibility
you know yeah and it's like not only
okay I'll send you myself and I don't
want to go get a box they send you the
label
okay so there's never been a better time
to digitally preserve your memories
visit legacy box calm today to get
started for a limited time they're
offering our listeners an exclusive
discount go to legacy box.com slash
toast to get 40% off your first order go
to legacy box.com
slash toast save 40% today get started
on preserving your past honestly that's
one of those companies where it's like
if it weren't for the toast I would have
never known about and I'm really glad
that I do also it reminds we have an
idea I thought of yesterday let's hear
it for a company like I could have
thought of legacy box like I can't
believe I'm not the owner of that
company that's upsetting but no but at
least you're working with them now yes
never too late I'm reaping some of the
benefits there needs to be a company
because I had bought a dress for your
wedding a while ago and then like the
day before your wedding mean you ran
around town going to get new dresses
because I decided that I hid my dress
but I ended up wearing the original
dress which is always how it works out
so we have these two dresses that I now
have to return to Macy's and I just
don't want to there needs to be some
sort of service because whether it's I
order something online or order it in
the mail unless it's like ASOS or
revolve that make it so easy like if I
had to print a label if I should go to
UPS and I could go to the store like
more often than not I forgot about it
and then it gets too late and I can't
return it
like there needs to be a service that I
there like does it for you or something
just a thought yeah yeah it's not
my best idea yeah it's no barf Alice but
it'll do yeah it's um it's tough because
it's really just taking out like the one
step of printing a label no but it's
like getting tape in about printing a
label getting tape in a box and going to
UPS yeah and I live in a building where
sometimes they let me just leave in and
they'll like shove it in the UPS box but
like more often than not I gotta go when
it's really annoying
really you can't just leave it
downstairs and tell you PS con sometimes
you can but if you do PS ground they
don't have to take it because they're
not paying for pickup interesting
factoids that are well in today okay so
we are going to do another episode
patron things really I feel like we've
barely scratched the surface I know but
it's like we're going on an hour and a
half I know and I'm dead and we've been
talking about it for an hour and I don't
even talk we must have talked about
something so just before we sign up I
just want to thank a bunch of people
that made this day incredible first of
all birch urban design like a vision
like I thought I had a big imagination
counselor snitch bah bah bah like they
the salient Gomberg you know and I have
good taste like I thought I knew what I
wanted and they just like blew it up on
a scale like I don't know what took my
breath away more the ceremony or the
ballroom like it was just such
perfection the ballroom was like
beautiful Elsa's castle frozen out Lake
black tag frozen it was so beautiful
oozing and then they added like these
little pink touches to hark back to like
the ceremony it was just so beautiful
everything was just thought of and and
done in such a beautiful way and I just
I felt like I felt so unworthy no yeah
it should I can't believe it was all for
me they do amazing work and they're so
much fun to work with and they make it
so easy and they take a lot of the
stress out of it because it can be
stressful I want to thank my wedding
planner Michael Russo who just helped
with those logistics that I was worried
about it like who's gonna talk to who
and vendor meals and this and that looks
like really concerned about getting me
tea at all times like during the weekend
cuz I was being like such a drama so
funny I was like my nodes need
lubrication and he was like bring me tea
like every couple hours he's just
incredible his energy is just like so
calming which is exactly what I needed
if I had someone in them over the past
eight months he was just like why is
this when is that why having all this I
would have lost my mind and he was
always just making me feel like I'm
right on track and like we are good to
go and that is what I needed
I want to thank Anthony Vasquez and his
whole team especially one for just like
understanding the premium content of it
all and the the lack of treacherous like
potential right and like getting it done
and we got every picture that we needed
we took them
using pictures outside bridal party
pictures him under sitting like it I'm
just so excited to see all the photos
and I'm gonna be posting photos at like
I will not post a real to a photo this
off of my wedding at least for another
week so I I think I will post probably
30 more times and also you know until
the like start trippin out like really
engagements there until I post a wedding
photo that gets less than 10,000 likes
I'm out but that's not a challenge you
guys please like and I want to thank my
videographer Laurette who just stayed
out of my way no I didn't even know you
had a videographer because it was so
behind the scenes I had two people and
they just like we're so behind the
scenes I'm gonna have all the footage
they're gonna come giving me videos soon
and so if I did like them just like high
quality like my I know you're busy and I
know you know what to do and I'm not
trying so I said all I can do for my
youtuber oh no like you performing at my
wedding which I'm just so thankful for
him so think by the time something fell
like I loved it I loved it more and you
say I'm available for bookings if you
would like me to sing coming home at
your wedding and I want to thank Mary
Ann Bennett and element music they were
spectacular the wedding was everything
that was over top but it was the next
level with them like no one could stop
talking about the band I knew of them
from your wedding so I knew they were
gonna be incredible but like you when
you say like there's it's an amazing
band it's like how amazing can they be
she is just so talented and she just
made me so excited about everything
every time we met into a meeting any
time I went to any wedding meeting I'm
just in a bad mood I'm like you know
this is like tortures I can't think
about it but she just made everything so
fun she has the best energy and she just
like she crushed it she took all the
questions in the doubt out you know like
she could be playing in an empty room
and it's gonna be the best party of all
time so Trevor meant her enough I'm sure
she's very busy in booking but element
music Mary Ann Bennett thank you to
everyone who was a part of my day the
guests everyone for bringing their best
energy all the people who came so far
from Dallas like that's so nice so many
out-of-towners and like everyone really
contributed to it and it's like I it was
perfect I wouldn't have changed one
thing no and huge thank you to Renee
Perry for just like making my night yes
oh my ad keep calling her that I know
and you don't have a much just I didn't
want sweet Vanessa Williams for
character on who is by the way an
incredible dancer and a precious gem of
a woman a precious gem of a woman I
[ __ ] love her like I went up to her
and you know as someone you know who is
you know somewhat recognizable like you
never want to annoy someone when you
and then like I love love love meeting
people but like when people sit down and
have dinner with me like it's like you
know I'm so I've enough to re night
Perry I'm like I really want to bother
you like I'm famous too it's fine like
us famous people mm-hmm but I love you
and I'm like you're it's just so true
like every show she's been in she
touches turns to gold
totally Ugly Betty yes what we said Ugly
Betty Desperate Housewives obviously but
she didn't get enough time yeah on
despereaux's wives and I also want to
thank the Pierre hotel and Bill Center
who works there who's just a class act
and they just made my life so easy
everything was thought of when we walked
out when we kissed you stepped on my
veil and pulled it off in a trip but
it's okay I just want to say it wasn't
me but okay oh hey who has it then do
you want it thrown a now yeah it was my
girl when I was trying to get her off of
it and then I pulled it from underneath
her and she ripped it it's a stiletto I
can tell you because I told my god she
was like yeah it was called yeah oh my
god [ __ ] [ __ ] anyways no but it's
like we ran out of our ceremony and they
swooped us away right there to [ __ ] it
was perfect it was perfect they just do
such a nice job and it smells so good I
can't stress that enough and bill and
Chris just made my night a dream it was
it is a dream and exactly 90 minutes
later while we're so on time 12 o'clock
on the top we missed eleven eleven but
with a fairytale wedding like that who
needs wishes well actually I need a wish
I was Jackie and Zach a lifetime of
happiness it was such a great wedding I
loves being at the center of attention
for like five minutes it was really
awesome for me but for everyone involved
it was just like a night full of joy and
laughter and happiness and just like
teeny [ __ ] vibes rocks teeny vibes
rock Stinney vibes that's basically
that's basically it that's what it's
boils down to it really is okay we'll be
back tomorrow I feel doing their teacher
episode with more wedding really I
didn't even scratch the surface
exclusive photos exclusive videos you
know we're almost at 10,000 patrons and
we said when we get to 10,000 feet runs
we're stalking them a party plan by
burch plan oh yes I'm gonna bet such a
good idea okay we are doing a 10,000
party every patron can come and
everybody trying it's a plus-one like in
case I come so it'll be 20,000 people at
our party lol I hope we ready burst
yes it'll be it's gonna be so epic and
then this week we have so much coming up
we have Nick vile Thursday sitting down
just one-on-one getting to know him
getting to know us getting down to the
bottom of the beef I kind of want to
write down my apology because you want
to
letter when Ron went to your Sam that's
the other night when we were at bed and
you went home u.s. dandy Dorfman why she
had sex with you and that's when we
started to eat you
yeah now we kind of like you and we're
sorry and you're a bigger man than we
will ever be because we're women right
and but you're a better man than we were
there because you had an opportunity to
sign her name and you did it the song
better man was written about you I can't
believe we're saying that I know if you
had showed us this clip like we would
have we would have said what does this
show become yeah we really lost
ourselves famous gotten to us right but
no the show has been coming around
growth mm-hmm totally all right well
thanks Jax with sharing things swimming
open thanks to a stars for coming out
strong today for making zeki o the
trending wedding that it was that the
treading yeah thank you all for enjoying
and caring about it so much cuz that
means it even more exciting for me I was
like wow I'm so special you are special
it was a special night there were
special couple and it was just so great
I love you guys we'll be back tomorrow
patreon.com slash morning toys for more
wedding premiumness tickets available at
girls no job to come I'm coming to
Dallas I'm Kona Foxwoods I'm coming all
over the country Houston lebretia
California Irvine California see all the
dates at girls on job calm
you